well littlefinger as you recall from
season three was dispatched north
to mary lisa aaron and
bring the veil of aaron into the realm
on the lannister side to deliver
that to uh to joffrey
and he departs in his ship
long before the wedding takes place
so he's safely gone
and when bad things start happening in
king's landing well he can't be blamed
he left
weeks ago and meanwhile he has a cat's
paw in
king's landing uh cerdanto's the red
the the drunken knight that uh sansa
saved from joffrey's wrath in the first
episode of uh season two
uh when he disgraced himself at the
tournament and joffrey was about to put
him to death
sansa convinced him no make him your
fool instead so cerdantos is
dancing and prancing around and playing
the fool and hoping joffrey won't kill
him today and he doesn't annoy anybody
but meanwhile he's also approaching
sansa
and what she doesn't know and hopefully
what the audience won't know until they
see it act out is
he's actually acting as a cat's paw for
littlefinger who has set this whole
thing in motion
so when the wedding occurs and uh
the bodies are flying and the
accusations are flying
sansa has disappeared where has she gone
well in the middle of the chaos and the
confusion cerdanto smuggled her out
to a small boat which road across
blackwater bay to where littlefinger's
ship is
cleverly waiting and now
sansa is with peter baelish on her way
north
well the main defense that the night's
watch has is the wall the wall is
formidable it's 700 feet high
you don't even need to shoot arrows you
can drop rocks
you can throw over boiling water
boiling oil boiling tar on people below
in addition there's only one gate
there's a a very small narrow gate that
only a few people can get through
easily blocked easily defended you just
stand people on top of it and you rain
stuff
directly down be it arrows or spears or
rocks
or chunks of ice or what have you
on anyone trying to get through the gate
becomes very difficult
you lose a lot of people that way you
can try to climb the wall
but if you're trying to climb the wall
while people are on top of the wall
defending it
and you're clinging to the ice you're
working your way up a couple hundred
feet and you still got 500
feet to go and now people are throwing a
piece of ice or rocks or
spears down on you that's almost
impossible too
the wall is very thick so you can't
really hack your way through it
not against defense again it would take
way too long
that's been tried too you can't dig
under it so all of these favor the
the defenders everything about that the
wall is a very formidable defensive
fortification
what mance has going for of course is
numbers the letter that davos found is
the letter that
maester amen sent out from the wall
calling on all of the five kings who
were then fighting
to send help to the wall because the
cold winds are rising
the the white walkers are moving the
whites the dead
are coming back to life um it's a pretty
serious situation
and uh stannis indeed when it comes in
it gets buried in a bunch of this other
male and doesn't get attended but davos
in the process of learning to read
comes across this thing and stannis has
realized that he's going about this all
wrong that
he's been trying to become king to save
the realm
when he should have been saving the
realm to become king and the last thing
that mance raider accept
expects is a is a large force of mounted
knights
uh suddenly erupting from the woods onto
his
flanks as he's uh battering at the wall
he thinks all of the enemy is right in
front of him he doesn't think there's
any
foe left north of the wall but stannis
has
come north of the wall and when you know
stannis force of
of disciplined mounted knights takes
them unaware and suddenly is rolling
through their camps
the army shatters